I've been curious in a completely
unrelated to the sex style we can get
back into that later if anything comes
out but I when you announced that you
were doing moist Esports I was like damn
that seems like a really hard thing to
break in yeah yeah so like how did that
all come about because I am fascinated
by that do you want to explain moistly
yeah yeah yeah sure so moist Esports
it's our Esports org so it started kind
of accidentally it's something we've
always wanted to do but in August of
last year a smash player by the name of
cola who had competed in our tournaments
and won them he hit me up on Twitter
he's like hey I'm lobbying for Summit
which is a huge Smash Bros tournament he
was like can you retweet this and I was
like bet but I'll do one better I'll
make a whole org around it and really
hype it up and then it actually like he
got in it actually looked like you know
Cola had a chance of winning it Esports
could be like a legitimate presence so
then we ended up signing Aaron which is
another Smash Bros player who's a friend
Nicola also at Summit and we did really
well and we were like gotta keep this
going so then we just put our foot on
the gas it's super hard to get into
because it's so expensive yeah I was
gonna say I heard the one thing is that
you know the reason why a lot of these
uh
the uh what are they called the I don't
know Esports agencies
yeah organizations yeah I mean they're
all venture capital right yeah hundreds
of millions of dollars because they just
bleed money it's just Imaging money for
ever basically I think I don't remember
exactly but I think it's only two of
them are profitable right now and it's
not from their Esports it's 100 thieves
because of all the merch they pump yeah
I believe the other one was TSM yes TSM
because they have like a massive fan
base that goes all the way back and no
other Esports agency they're just money
no they're all bleeding money I'm sure
there's some that maybe make profit here
and there but for the most part you're
bleeding one that sounds like a bobble
well it's I think for those like for
companies that try and like get into the
Esports scene to try and like because
there's a huge multiple because everyone
wants to be in there so they try and
build it for three years sell it for
like a I think it's like a 10x multiple
right now so they'll try and make like a
big exit with a big influx of cash right
I think for them it's definitely more of
like bubbleish maybe even like a bit of
a scam on their end because you're doing
it just to sell it like you're kind of
misleading everyone yeah for us we just
love the space yeah so we're in rocket
League now we're in Apex we're in Split
gate Smash Bros Guilty Gear brawlhalla
like it's just really fun things to
watch because for us we do it for the
content like the watch parties are fun
to watch so even though it's massively
negative in terms of financial gain the
content I think is priceless yeah I
guess when you say it like that it's
like what better way to get into a bunch
of Esports than just have your team to
root for exactly yeah literally all of
them yeah yeah 100 watching the chat
like spam moist Esports emotes and like
talk about them like it's so great it's
super fun oh that sounds like so much
fun because yeah because like being kind
of a big league watches yeah yeah we
don't play it we don't play it just just
for the record
we don't play it but we love to watch it
and I know there's a big problem right
now where most of like the North
American organizations they like over
they overplay no overpay they play a
salary like like it's so inflated right
um and the players suck you know yeah
unfortunately it is unfortunately like
uh like the organizations don't perform
well internationally at all but they're
like the players just like the salaries
just keeping cool when you're a good
player you go to America to retire yeah
because you get the paycheck right I
think across all Esports American
players get paid the most yeah like
across the board yeah it's it's a lot
yeah yeah but like I guess I think
you're going about it the right way
where it's just like a fun branding
thing as well yeah you just sometimes
you just want to get fun do something
fun in the space you know yeah and I'm
sure eventually like with merch and we
just got skins in rocket League like I'm
sure it won't always be like a huge
massive Financial loss like right now
it's all out of pocket but maybe at some
point it starts to be self-sustaining
yeah are you really deep into the
financial side or are you more like a
hey I just want to do this someone else
handled the money part absolutely
your financial advisors like hey Charlie
I don't know what's going on man but
this seems like a bag
so pretty much all of like my twitch
Revenue goes right into moist Esports at
this point it's just pretty much all
filters there to keep it all sustaining
because I've been sure the whole you
made the video about the Omega Strikers
this cool thing where they said that I
don't I don't know how the tournament
functioned the how did it works people
could play for your team yeah so like in
the game you go in you choose what team
you want to play for it was like me
raking was the other big one from Brazil
Lily Peach who had a team dyrus had a
team yeah you just go click I'll compete
for your team every win you get com
accounted for them whoever had the most
wins after 10 days got the first prize
which was three percent of the net
revenue of the game which is a crazy
offer yeah so we went Hog Wild I saw the
results and it was like 10 million uh 2
million and it was like okay I think I
think you won yeah I mean that could
have that was awesome it was it's a fun
game too like it could amount to no
money or it could amount to some but it
seemed like an opportunity worth it
because yeah fun game and it could lead
to something that helped moist the
Esports yeah because I think you
mentioned your video right that you
mainly recently want to do is you're
like hey all this money's gonna go and
watch Esports yeah I mean that's just
crazy like it seems like a like a
colossal undertake it is it's a lot to
get into the field like do you see it
making money like profitably in like the
next five years or is that like even
even further down the line five years
hopefully yeah five years a long time to
keep going yeah it'd be nice within five
years but obviously are there any more
games you want to get into in terms of
like Esports that you want to bring
under yep so we've been looking a lot at
like CS go valorant kind of shot
themselves in the foot with their whole
franchising I don't know if you guys
know about that but yeah he just hates
Valerian periods I think it's like the
most boring thing to watch yeah I'm a
fan to watch I don't play anymore yeah
yeah but yeah like all the big ones
League of course is a pipe dream but
that's super expensive yeah on their
spots like 15 20 million yeah it's a lot
it's that's a wonderful Mexico
yeah what do you think makes like a good
esport because it seems like when
whenever a new Hive game gets released
now everyone's like okay when's the
Esports you know when's the Esports
starting the OverWatch League was like a
I mean they manufactured it right yeah
and then that kind of crashed them both
so bad it was 20 million dollars just to
be in it it was so dumb and I remember
because like I because I liked OverWatch
when it first launched and I was like
okay let's try watching the esport of
this and I just could not follow it is a
miserable Esports I think it's a [ __ ] it
just wasn't fun it was two tanks
everyone's just shooting at tanks
forever yeah then dump alt rinse and
repeat it wasn't a funny Sport and
there's like no time to explain I think
league has that perfect balance of
spectator sport where there's enough
breathing breathing room where you can
kind of explain things if a friend's
watching with you or you know you can
kind of talk through it and the games
are long they're like 40 minutes and
it's very obvious when something is
happening yeah whereas in OverWatch
you're like I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening Genji killed my whole team
and I'm like how do I explain this like
so you could have reset every time he
kills right but then Anna news role to
empower him and so like it's like
actually it's pretty cool it's like what
like it doesn't make sense if you don't
know the game I think for esport to be
like hype to watch it's got to be fast
paced and it's got to be something you
can look at knowing nothing about the
game and understand yeah so rocket
League's perfect for that I mean it's
soccer yeah cars yeah you know exactly
what you're looking at yeah
it's pretty easy as well well this is
like any fighting game yeah it's two
players in a fighting game most of the
time they fight each other you know
exactly yeah yeah and fighting Esports
seems the most hype it's like the crowds
oh my God there's just the community in
general just they just like I want to
get into fighting games just to be a
part of this community so they are
massively hype
just seeing the crowds like scream and
jump around whenever anyone's doing
anything and it's literally Pikachu
fighting Jigglypuff yeah and people are
losing this
this is so surreal when you sit back and
think about it but like it's awesome
it's just like the perfect level of
toxicity as well where it's just like
everyone [ __ ] talking so nobody takes
anyone seriously exactly which other
Esports had that in a way that where it
was it worked but I guess because
fighting games just had it from the
ground up right that is one-on-one so
they can talk [ __ ] to each other whereas
it's like 5v5 it's much harder to start
talking yeah yeah because everyone you
see an interview league and it's just
like like 90 of interviews are like the
most boring generic PR interview of all
time and then you see fighting game
interviews and that's just like
everyone's talking [ __ ] it's so much fun
it's so much better yeah and like the
memes that come out of it as well I just
think about the fighting game Community
oh my God all like the compilations that
come out of like yeah
it's the best to watch salty Smash Bros
so good compilation 15. no it's so good
I think the only thing in my mind that
makes fighting games uh like not a great
uh oh my God I mean it's good spectating
but like on the level that like let me
let me hear you just because it's over
too fast they're fast so like when you
get like a street fighter attacking
those games can go by in a single combo
and it's like you know you watch League
you can go to the toilet you can come
back and maybe you miss something maybe
you didn't but in fighting games if you
miss it or you you went out to get some
snacks from the store like the bracket
is totally changed and like it's hard to
follow the characters and then like you
know you can build up these teams in
longer form games and longer tournaments
yeah whereas you know in fighting games
you get knocked out and then it's like
okay well my guy's gone I definitely I
don't really know who like Cheetos xx4
is and like yeah yeah you know it's it's
I feel like the story lines aren't there
as often like the way that they could
because you can manufacture it more yeah
I feel with something like Evo they do a
good job with like yeah yeah you know
creating this because when you have
people who come back time and time again
then you can make stories yeah yeah
right you have like the the top 10
players who are normally at most events
then you can start making the narratives
right yeah and if they're there a lot
then it works yeah
um but even then it's over in minutes
well I think the difference is that
something like League you know you have
organizations you know no yeah fighting
games is very much here is the
individual player yeah it's only like
one-on-one so it's like far easier to
follow The Narrative of this
organization like you do with like
traditions for sure it works yeah yeah
especially Sports yeah story arc
we have a great story I think so